so you have very, very uncertain data.
So how can we detect and correct these inconsistencies?
How can we represent that form of uncertainty?
It's difficult. One thing you can do
is document each step of the process,
not only coding the historical information
but what we call the meta-historical information,
how is historical knowledge constructed,
documenting each step.
That will not guarantee that we actually converge
toward a single story of Venice,
but probably we can actually reconstruct
a fully documented potential story of Venice.
Maybe there's not a single map.
Maybe there are several maps.
The system should allow for that,
because we have to deal with a new form of uncertainty,
which is really new for this type of giant databases.
And how should we communicate
this new research to a large audience?
Again, Venice is extraordinary for that.
With the millions of visitors that come every year,
it's actually one of the best places
to try to invent the museum of the future.
Imagine, horizontally you see the reconstructed map
of a given year,
and vertically, you see the document
that served the reconstruction,
paintings, for instance.
Imagine an immersive system that permits
to go and dive and reconstruct the Venice of a given year,
some experience you could share within a group.
On the contrary, imagine actually that you start
from a document, a Venetian manuscript,
and you show, actually, what you can construct out of it,
how it is decoded,
how the context of that document can be recreated.
This is an image from an exhibit
which is currently conducted in Geneva
with that type of system.
So to conclude, we can say that
research in the humanities is about to undergo
an evolution which is maybe similar
to what happened to life sciences 30 years ago.
It's really a question of scale.
We see projects which are
much beyond any single research team can do,
and this is really new for the humanities,
which very often take the habit of working
in small groups or only with a couple of researchers.
When you visit the Archivio di Stato,
you feel this is beyond what any single team can do,
and that should be a joint and common effort.
So what we must do for this paradigm shift
is actually foster a new generation
of "digital humanists"
that are going to be ready for this shift.
I thank you very much.
(Applause)